this is the Jocko underground podcast
we're on number 62. this is number 62.
let me sitting here with Echo Charles
I was talking to uh
a guy at Camp well pretty much been to
been to every camp that I think I've
been to
Jiu Jitsu camp this is by the way origin
emerging camp and good guy uh We've
we've always hung out and
I've kind of watched his growth and
journey for lack of a better word over
the past few years anyways this time
shows up to camp
we're talking and he's going through a
really hard time like a surprisingly you
know when you just you see someone on a
trajectory and you're watching their
trajectory like oh this is a good
trajectory you're
and then all of a sudden they're just
off that trajectory like it's like this
space shuttle Columbia like you think
everything's going good like it just it
just goes sideways
so that's what's going on um he's a
former military guy he's been out of the
military for a pretty long time
but you know he started his own business
and he's doing pretty well but you know
it was a lot of hard work like a tough
business a lot of hard work kids the
whole nine yards everything's I mean
this is just the trajectory like oh yeah
you're doing well you've kind of pivoted
a little bit made some adjustments you
got the wife you got a bunch of kids
and if you were to ask me if you said
you know where do you think my life is
right now I would have been like okay
well you probably expanded your business
a little bit more you probably you know
this is but it was like no um
wife wants divorce
uh like just just total
uh
change right just a drastic change in
Direction in his life so
as we're talking through it and we spent
like an hour talking
as we're talking to it through it like
at one point he's like you know I might
have to sell the business you know
because they built up this business and
he might in order to settle with her he
might have to sell it
to sell the business
and which to me was weird because if you
sell the business you have no more
income you know so it's not like you can
sell and he goes no well he goes I'll
probably have to sell the business give
her a big chunk of the payout
and then I'll have to work at Home Depot
just to pay child support and I don't
know what I'm gonna do uh I just can't
figure out you know he's like I'm a
smart guy I think about it but I just
can't figure out what to do and so I'm
sitting there listening I'm thinking
about it for a while and um
finally I said you know I'm not smart
but
I know what I would do
and he was like well what I said if I
was in your situation I know what I
would do and he was like what and I said
I would start walking
and he's like well you know what do you
mean I said here let me explain this is
what's going on with you right now
you
just woke up like you just came to
Consciousness and you're you don't know
where you are and you're in the middle
of the Woods
and you're looking around and you see
trees and it's like
thick you can't even tell where the sun
is right but you you know you're in the
woods
you don't know where to go
and so what I would do is I would start
walking I would just pick like a
direction and I would start walking and
as I'm walking I would eventually find a
little terrain that's going downhill and
I'd follow that terrain downhill and
eventually I'd hit a stream
and this stream would actually be a
tributary into a a river and then from
the river I'd follow the river until I'd
hit a road and when I'd hit a road
events had follow the road to a town
somewhere and I figure things out right
I figured out where I was
and I'd be back and I'd be able to get
food and I'd put everything together
but I said what you're doing and this is
what I could tell from this conversation
I said what you're doing is you're just
standing there looking around
and you're trying to figure out where
the town is where civilization is and
you're waiting
trying to guess and looking around and
looking for Clues but there's no
freaking Clues you're in the middle of
the Woods
there's no clues there's no there's no
clues literally
you have to go and find it civilization
the town the thing is not going to come
to you you have to start walking
so that's what I would do and look
there's a obviously there's a hint of
like iterative decision making right you
don't know where you are you don't know
what to do start moving in some
direction and that'll give you some
clues or some indication or some
immediate feedback about where you are
and you can start assembling a better
picture of what's Happening
so
I know I'm not might not be the smartest
person in the world and you're smart
but you're not going to be able to do
anything without doing something
so you're gonna have to start walking
and then
we I went back to this Home Depot piece
and I said listen you know I've if I was
in your shoes okay I could get a job at
Home Depot
and I was like and you know what I got
my job at Home Depot my aisle would be
the freaking squared away aisle it and
after like a week and a half it'd be the
most squared away aisle in Home Depot
and I said in a few weeks the store
manager would look at me and be like hey
can you run these three aisles they'd
give me three files and then they'd give
me seven aisles and then they give me 12
aisles and then they give me the front
of the store and then eventually they'd
be like hey can you just run this store
because I'd be busting my ass and I'd be
making things happen I'd be building
relationships with people
and then eventually they'd be like hey
we want you to run this district with
all the Home Depots in this district and
then they go we want you to take this
region and eventually they'd be like hey
we want you to be the CEO of Home Depot
and we're laughing right because I'm not
that arrogant but we were I was making a
point
but I told this guy I was like look you
see working at Home Depot as a
punishment and I see it as an
opportunity
as an opportunity and by the way Home
Depot there's like you've heard a Home
Depot millionaires right it's a real
thing oh no what is it Home Depot
millionaires like in the early days of
Home Depot you could take stock options
when Home Depot wasn't that big and a
lot of people that were cashiers and you
know cleaners in the aisles they took
stock and you know now they're
millionaires
um
but that
reframing or the way you're looking at
things
and
seeing opportunities
instead of seeing punishments and
instead of seeing downturns in your life
seeing opportunities
it's just going to have such a much
better impact on the way
you where you get to because you know go
into like the
you know you're Jordan Peterson talking
about like aiming and you got to take
Aim right well this is a version of that
right yeah when I get in there and I
think hey I'm going to make this aisle
look awesome yeah look at what I'm
aiming at I'm aiming to improve and get
better and do a good job if I go in
there this sucks what am I aiming at
yeah I'm aiming at this sucking that's
actually where I'm gonna you know the
same thing we when we used to do uh
offensive driving
and when you're driving a car
if you start looking at like
if you gotta go between obstacles and
you start looking at one of those
obstacles you can hit that obstacle
that's you know there's like a tendency
that you're gonna hit the obstacle
you're gonna go where you're what what
you're looking at yeah same thing with
this if you think this job is going to
suck
well guess what the job is actually
going to suck now and
you're not going to do it well and
you're not going to get promoted and
you're not going to give be given more
responsibility you're not going to be
given any opportunities
so just be careful of that I think
that's a good lesson for everybody this
happens throughout yeah it doesn't
happen when I got Seal Team won
back in the day got Seal Team won
they're like clean toilets I'm like cool
let me rock and roll I'm gonna do this
really well
you think I wanted to clean toilets of
course not but I was like okay that's
what we're doing let's do this at one of
my friends
I had a different team made like his web
gear into like
custodial Attack Mode you know you put
like about like a holster with cleaner
in it another one's like a toilet brush
you know he's like running around ready
to respond you know he's having fun with
it and if he was just poking fun at it
it would have been like well that might
be a risky move but he was doing it like
no I'm ready to go like he he actually
was fired up about it so embrace it uh
so that's what I'm saying if you're in a
spot and you don't know what to do
and you're not sure where to go
and you don't know where the right
direction is start walking
and start looking for opportunities
and they'll show up
that's my word of the day thank you
Charles yeah I agree they in some people
talk about that where it's okay
he's far more ahead than it's because
it's not some people they look at it oh
my gosh I gotta start all over whatever
and a common that thing that I've heard
is you're technically not starting all
over because of all of your past
experience and knowledge or whatever so
even waking up in the woods like that's
perfect such a perfect year watch the
movie Memento yes I I did but my memory
of it's kind of vague oddly enough right
yeah yeah exactly right so and the way
they present that movie is like in
backwards Clips right which is kind of
part they try to mimic his thought
process and the way his brain works
because he doesn't have short-term
memory so
he'll just sort of come too just like in
the woods or whatever and something's
either going on or he's at a certain
place and he doesn't know how he got
there so he kind of refers to his
tattoos for his like notes so that's
kind of like in your analogy where
the tattoos is your past experience and
knowledge you know you can look at them
and whatever you don't have any assets
you don't have like
everything that you lost is gone it's
gone but you have knowledge which is
more powerful exactly right only the
knowledge in your head though you don't
have like the business you don't have
you know the access to all that so
that's gone that's like the guy's
memories you know so those are gone he
knows only what he can do moving forward
and he can use all the knowledge that he
has tattooed so it's kind of the same
deal in a way that's that's how it
struck me anyway
um so yeah he's kind of starting ahead
yeah oh definitely starting ahead yeah
and starting with no baggage
which is another way to look at it right
age and kids and stuff like that's those
are factors or whatever but yeah man
that's a good such a good way to look at
it where don't
when you say avoiding like the driving
thing where you're like yeah would you
call it offensive offensive driving
don't look at the obstacle yeah so it's
like you can't actively avoid an
obstacle just don't look for the app so
look for something else like look for
how you said opportunity or you know
drivable terrain have you heard me talk
about that
terrain exactly you're driving you're
like a accident ahead of you yeah and
you're just looking for drivable terrain
what where can I take this vehicle where
I'm not gonna die yeah and that's a real
positive thing so that's the another
thing you start walking in the woods
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
8.18 cents a month and if you can't
afford to support us we can still
support you just email assistance Jocko
underground.com and we'll get you taken
care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground